hagamos las configuraciones electrónicas
para el segundo periodo de la tabla
periódica y este justamente se encuentra
en el segundo renglón de la tabla muy
bien y si vemos muy bien podemos
observar que el primer elemento que
encontramos es el litio y éste cuenta
con tres electrones así que vamos a
trabajar con estos tres electrones para
el litio pero los primeros dos van a
caer dentro de la primera capa que ya
hemos hablado de él de esta primera capa
en el vídeo anterior verdad la primera
capa corresponde justamente cuando n es
igual a 1 y que por lo tanto l es igual
a 0 muy bien y por lo tanto estamos
hablando de un orbital es un orbital ese
que se encuentra en la en el primer
nivel de energía de hecho podríamos
dibujar este orbital verdad podríamos
ponerlo justo por aquí el orbital 1s y
aquí están los dos electrones digamos
con esta configuración de espín es
litio verdad para esta primera capa así
que el litio tiene 3 electrones los
primeros dos ya los hemos representado
así que ahora vamos a escribir la
configuración electrónica para el litio
muy bien y vamos a empezar escribiendo
lo digamos por aquí el litio digamos
tiene primero su primera capa llena
verdad el 1 s 2 esta primera capa ya
está llena así que para poner el tercer
electrón tenemos que saltar a una
segunda capa que hay que agregar para
poder para poder agregar el tercer
electrón del litio así que en esta
segunda capa n vale 2 y para el valor de
l tenemos dos opciones puede ser que le
valga 0 o bien puede ser que l valga
valga 1 muy bien en este primer caso
estaremos considerando sólo un orbital s
verdad
justamente estamos en el segundo nivel n
de energía y tendremos un orbital
sin embargo cuando estamos hablando de l
igual a 1
tenemos que considerar orbitales p muy
bien tenemos que considerar orbitales p
y de hecho son tres orbitales p muy bien
ahora bien los valores permitidos para
ml ml pueden ser menos 1 1 negativo 0 y
más 1 o 1 positivo muy bien ahí están
los valores posibles esos son los tres
posibles valores para ml y tenemos tres
orbitales p muy bien
así que vamos a dibujar estos orbitales
en nuestro diagrama de orbitales que
estamos pintando por acá verdad vamos a
poner primero el orbital 2s muy bien y
lo ponemos más arriba del 1 es porque
tiene está en el segundo nivel de
energía verdad tiene mayor energía
ahí está el 2 ese y luego tenemos los
orbitales p del segundo nivel de energía
y tenemos tres de ellos así que pintamos
nuestros tres orbitales p estos sería el
segundo nivel de energía los orbitales p
y los he puesto ligeramente más arriba
porque tienen mayor energía verdad estos
orbitales que tienen más energía uno de
ellos sería el orbital 2 px el segundo
de ellos sería dos pelé y el tercero
sería el orbital dos pesetas pero en
realidad no importa cuál es cuál
simplemente los vamos a dibujar y con
eso basta muy bien así que regresemos
con el litio nos hemos encargado de dos
electrones del litio
pero en realidad tiene 3 electrones así
que el tercer electrón debe ir en este
orbital en este orbital 2s verdad porque
pues porque la energía va aumentando en
esta dirección verdad hacia arriba la
energía va aumentando en esa dirección
muy bien así que el siguiente electrón
debería estar acomodado en el siguiente
orbital 2s
así que vamos a ponerlo y por lo tanto
la configuración electrónica del litio
es 1 s 2 y tendremos 2 s 1 y recordemos
que el 2 es por el nivel de energía s es
porque es un orbitales de hecho voy a
marcar los dos es el nivel 2 de energía
ese es el tipo de orbital y el 1
corresponde a que sólo hay un electrón
en dicho orbital muy bien ahora podemos
seguir con el siguiente elemento verdad
que es el berilio y que tiene un número
atómico de 4 es decir tenemos que
trabajar con 4 electrones así que con
respecto al litio en realidad tenemos un
electrón ex la verdad así que podemos
poner ese cuarto electrón del berilio en
este orbital y justamente hay que
emparejar lo con un spin hacia abajo muy
bien así que vamos a escribir la
configuración electrónica de el berilio
nuevamente tendríamos 1 s 2
ahora tendríamos 2 s 2 verdad y de esta
forma ya hemos llenado los dos orbitales
s recordemos que cada orbital puede
sostener un máximo de 2 electrones y ya
hemos llenado estos dos orbitales s muy
bien así que cuando nos movamos al
siguiente elemento que sería el boro y
para el boro no se vamos a utilizar otro
color
digamos este color para el boro el boro
tiene 5 electrones así que vamos a
escribir la configuración electrónica
para el boro hasta ahora para el boro
tenemos 1 s 2 2s 2 y tenemos que
acomodar un quinto electrón y la
pregunta es dónde va ese quinto electrón
bueno el quinto electrón tiene que ir en
el siguiente orbital disponible y por lo
tanto lo vamos a poner ese electrón
este orbital en uno de los orbitales p
con más detalle en uno de los orbitales
2 p verdad estamos en el segundo nivel
de energía y por lo tanto la
configuración electrónica de el boro del
boro sería 1 s 2 2 s 2 quizás debería
corregir un poquito eso 2 s 2 y 2 p 1
indicando que el quinto electrón del
boro fue a dar
digamos lo acomodamos en un orbital 2 p
muy bien y ahora vamos a movernos con el
siguiente elemento este elemento ahora
es el carbono verdad que tiene 6
electrones vamos a hacerlo con azul así
que tenemos que pensar ahora en un nuevo
electrón y sabemos que va a estar en un
orbital p verdad en un orbital p del
segundo nivel de energía la pregunta es
cuál de estos orbitales p es el que va
almacenado o el que va a tener más bien
el sexto electrón del carbono así que
tenemos que pensar en algo llamado la
regla de junta
ustedes disculparán en realidad no sé
bien cómo se pronuncia correctamente del
idioma alemán así que vamos a llamarlo
simplemente la regla de junts que nos
dice que nuestro objetivo es minimizar
la repulsión de electrones en este en
estos orbitales verdad así que pensemos
vamos vamos a dibujar los orbitales p
por aquí abajo
aquí tenemos los orbitales p por aquí
abajo de hecho ya tenemos un electrón
aquí justamente lo habíamos colocado en
el caso anterior en el boro y quizás una
primera opción es que coloquemos el otro
electrón con una espina hacia abajo en
el mismo orbital que la anterior verdad
pero eso no tiene nada de sentido verdad
porque estamos poniendo un electrón en
el mismo orbital y eso hace que los
electrones estén realmente cerca en el
espacio así que si pensamos en un
orbital p
recordemos que el orbital p más o menos
se ve
ok debería hacerlo con más cuidado se ve
digamos si estamos poniendo unos ejes
más o menos de ese estilo y pensamos en
este orbital p
ok digamos que aquí se encuentra nuestro
primer electrón si colocamos el otro
electrón en ese mismo orbital estarían
muy cerca y eso no tiene sentido así que
lo que tendríamos que hacer es en
realidad colocarlo en otro lugar no
debería ir justamente aquí tendríamos
que colocarlo por ejemplo en otro de los
orbitales pero recordemos que esto es
por ejemplo se verían más o menos así
este sería uno y el tercero iría más o
menos así entonces no sé podríamos
acomodarlo en este otro orbital p y en
realidad lo puse con una espina hacia
arriba porque resulta ser que esto
mantener los espines paralelos ayuda a
minimizar la repulsión de los electrones
quizás por por razones muy complicadas y
de hecho yo creo que deben seguir
haciendo investigación en este hecho
verdad así que por eso es que he puesto
el electrón en otro orbital pero
manteniendo los espines paralelos que
nos ayudan a mantener la energía baja
para el átomo en este caso así que
estaremos colocando
el sexto electrón del carbono en otro
orbital distinto y por lo tanto ahora
podríamos escribir la configuración
electrónica del carbono verdad
tendríamos para el carbono tendríamos el
1 ese 22 ese 2 y después tendremos dos
p2 verdad indicando que tenemos dos
electrones en los orbitales p en los
orbitales 2 p ahora vamos con el
nitrógeno vamos a no sé vamos a utilizar
un color verde
vamos con el nitrógeno que tiene 7
electrones muy bien y hasta ahora
podríamos ir avanzando en la
configuración electrónica del nitrógeno
sería 1 s 2 2s 2 y ahora hay que pensar
qué ocurre con el séptimo electrón del
nitrógeno que deberá estar en alguno de
los orbitales
pero nuevamente siguiendo la regla de
jun no vamos a agregar un electrón en
alguno de los orbitales que ya estén
ocupados y no tendremos que agregarlo en
uno de los orbitales desocupados y
resulta como habíamos mencionado que si
los si ponemos los espines paralelos
entonces ayudamos a minimizar la energía
así que lo colocamos con el spin hacia
arriba y podríamos concluir que el
nitrógeno tiene una configuración
electrónica 1 s 2 2s 2 y 2 p 3 muy bien
ahora vamos con el siguiente atom con el
siguiente elemento que en este caso
sería el oxígeno y vamos a trabajarlo
con naranja y el oxígeno tiene 8
electrones verdad un total de 8
electrones así que veamos donde
pondríamos ahora el octavo electrón para
el oxígeno hasta ahora tenemos digamos
en su configuración electrónica
tendríamos 1 s 2
2 s 2 y ahora hay que agregar un octavo
electrón verdad pero ahora que ya están
todos nuestros orbitales 2p ocupados lo
único que nos queda es colocarlo en
alguno de ellos pero con el spin
orientado hacia abajo muy bien así que
ahí tenemos el octavo electrón para el
oxígeno y ahora podríamos escribir en su
configuración electrónica 2 p 4 verdad y
notemos en realidad los los super
índices que por ejemplo aquí es 2 2 y 4
nos dan nos están dando el total de
electrones que tiene este elemento dos
más dos son cuatro más dos más cuatro
son ocho que es justamente lo que tiene
el oxígeno verdad es el número total de
electrones que representan la
configuración electrónica para el
oxígeno ahora vamos a movernos con el
flúor muy bien y para eso vamos a
utilizar otro color verde para el flúor
y este flúor tiene
un total de 9 electrones así que
nuevamente vamos a emparejar nuestros
espines agregamos un noveno electrón
aquí digamos con con el espín orientado
hacia abajo y podemos escribir su
configuración electrónica como 1 s 2 2 s
2 y 2 p 5 muy bien y vamos ahora con el
último de los de los elementos que se
encuentran en el segundo periodo que
sería el neón que tiene un total de 10
electrones muy bien así que el el décimo
electrón simplemente puede caber en este
último espacio de los orbitales 2 p y
nuevamente el espín tendrá que ir
orientado hacia abajo verdad así que la
configuración electrónica del neón sería
1 s 2 2 s 2 y 2 p
6 así que notemos que en realidad ya no
tenemos más espacios para colocar
electrones en el primero
ni en el primer día en el segundo nivel
de energía es verdad estamos
completamente llenos de hecho la segunda
capa está completamente llena muy bien
así que si quisiéramos agregar otro
electrón
entonces tendríamos que agregar una
nueva capa verdad y eso nos dice que
tendríamos que ir al tercer nivel de
energía y ahora puedes ir notando un
patrón aquí que está emergiendo en la
tabla periódica como dijimos digamos en
la configuración electrónica del
hidrógeno que se encuentra justamente
aquí déjenme poner con otro color y
bueno que se encuentra justamente aquí
su configuración electrónica terminaba
con 1 s 1 verdad mientras que si nos
fijamos en el helio su configuración
electrónica terminaba con 1 s 2 verdad y
luego nos movemos al segundo nivel de
energía de que no hay cambiar de color y
si nos fijamos en el litio el litio
termina con 2 s 1 verdad mientras que el
berilio termina con 2 s 2
vamos bien y ahora si nos fijamos en los
siguientes elementos que hemos trabajado
por ejemplo en el boro este termina con
2 p 1 el carbono termina con dos p2 el
nitrógeno termina con 2 p 3
el oxígeno termina con 2 p 4 el flúor
termina con 2 p 5 y el neón termina con
2 p 6 así que es fácil notar que estas
seis cajas de la tabla periódica
representan nuestros orbitales 2 p
verdad de hecho estos dos estas dos
cajas que tenemos aquí representan
nuestros nuestro orbital 2s mientras que
las seis cajas que tenemos de este otro
lado representan los tres orbitales 2 p
así que fijándote en estos patrones en
la tabla periódica te puede ayudar
cuando estás escribiendo las
configuraciones electrónicas simplemente
tienes que sentarte y fijarte en la
tabla periódica para escribirlas
una vez que ya hayas obtenido bastante
práctica así que asegúrate de hacer todo
esto de nuevo y pensar en las
configuraciones electrónicas cuando
estés poniendo los electrones piensa
cómo se relaciona con la estructura de
la tabla periódica